[Musique]
certains moments on n'est pas crû
davantage en la révolution quand dieu ou
davantage c'était pas du même ordre
d'ailleurs pour moi ça allait un peu
ensemble un peu trop d'ailleurs je le
regrette maintenant
pour parce que c'est une confusion
regrettable
je suis maintenant convaincu que le
totalitarisme est le fruit d' d'une
certaine passion religieuse frustré et
qui a d'ailleurs été malheureuse parce
que précisément les chrétiens non pas
celui donné une réponse valable mais
vous est ce qu'on appelle un gain de
gauche au nom non pense pas non non
enfin les chrétiens puis j'ai pris des
engagements
étaient à gauche je suis un poc des gens
de gauche dans la résistance n'est ni
dans l'intérêt ni à lille
anticolonialiste avait été au moins je
suis chrétien je suis de gauche
peut-être mais enfin et c'est n'est plus
aussi n'être qu autrefois jean marie
domenach mais est-ce que l'heureuse idée
de base c'est moins net contre x parce
que t'es trop has been on a peut-être
bien entendu la fois ça tient aussi un
certain à une certaine énergie vitale
n'y a pas de questions on sait pas
seulement ça non ce que je voulais dire
c'est maintenant il ya beaucoup de gens
de gauche qui croient dans nom des idées
qu'on appelait de droite d'autrefois
dieu grande affaire
enfin c'est là qu'on a faites votre vie
quand la base oui la marge certaine
façon oui la grande affaire peut-être
pas mais finalement assez il est
finalement dans ce livre qui circule ce
que je crois il me semble que vous
parlez vous parler de dieu mais vous en
parlez moins que de l'histoire que de la
philosophie
japonais parce qu'il n'ya pas en parler
moi je suis toujours stupéfait lâche un
peu comme françois dion quand je reçois
des traités de sur dieu sur 500 pages je
comprends pas pourquoi il faut 500 pages
pour parler de dieu je préfère un poème
[Musique]